I'm very happy to win the first match for me today.
I never beat Andy before so I was very excited to play today.
And I'm very happy the way I played today.
I had more confidence, obviously.
I was a different player than last year and I had good results.
Best year so far.
I think I was hitting more aggressively...
...and I had more confidence and everything worked well today.
I was a little bit nervous when I got into the stadium,...
...because this is a huge stadium,...
...a lot of people, almost packed, and playing Andy first match.
So I was nervous, a little bit,...
...but at the same time I was really excited for today's match...
...and this is the first opportunity for me to play London Tour Finals.
I was a bit excited to play today.
Yeah, I knew this is a very important match.
First match is always a struggle, a little bit.
But I'll try to play a little bit relaxed, maybe for the second and third match,...
...but hopefully I can qualify for the semifinal.